Salut, moi c'est Guillaume Hachez. Bienvenue dans Septante Minutes Avec. Cet épisode est sans doute le plus clivant que j'ai produit jusqu'à présent.
Dans le passé, mes invités ont à peu près tous exprimé des idées avec lesquelles on peut être d'accord ou pas, mais clairement, c'était jamais des points de vue trop polémiques.
Ici, c'est différent puisque mon invitée est militante de la tête aux pieds. Cette semaine, j'ai rencontré Nadia Geerts, prof de philo à la Haute École de Bruxelles, que certains appellent la Caroline Fourest belge.
Elle s'est souvent prononcée dans les médias sur les questions du port du voile islamique dans les écoles et sur son souhait de voir arriver en Belgique une république sur le modèle français.
Du coup, forcément, chers auditeurs, il y en a parmi vous qui ne sont pas du tout d'accord. Et c'est pas grave, y a vraiment aucun souci.
Mon objectif avec ce podcast, c'est d'accueillir des invités insolites, d'explorer des sujets dont on ne parle pas forcément ailleurs, pas de faire de la propagande.
D'ailleurs, petite parenthèse, mais j'ai réalisé qu'en fait, sur les huit épisodes que j'ai publiés jusqu'à présent, il y a une parité presque parfaite au niveau des invités, tant au niveau du sexe qu'au niveau politique.
Et ça, c'est cool parce que j'avais pas fait exprès et que quelque part, ça montre que j'arrive à me diversifier dans mes choix d'invités.
Bref, tout ça pour vous dire que c'est tout à fait OK de ne pas être d'accord avec les propos qu'utilisent mon invitée, parce qu'à côté de ça, dans cet épisode, on fait le point sur l'histoire de la laïcité en Belgique,
la polarisation de la société, la monarchie et tout ça.
Voilà, bonne écoute. Hey, bonjour à tous. Pour ce huitième épisode, j'ai l'immense plaisir de recevoir Nadia Geerts. Nadia Geerts, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Vous êtes agrégée en philosophie et prof de philo à la Haute École de Bruxelles. Vous êtes membre du conseil d'administration du Centre d'action laïque, qui est une ASBL dont l'objectif est de promouvoir la laïcité.
On reviendra là-dessus plus tard. Vous êtes essayiste, mais vous êtes aussi surtout une militante laïque.
Peut-être une première question pour commencer légèrement : d'où ça vous est venu, en fait, cet intérêt pour les sujets que sont les religions et la laïcité en Belgique ?
Ben, c'est pas une question simple, en fait. Ou en tout cas, c'est pas une question à laquelle je vais pouvoir répondre rapidement.
En fait, c'est intéressant parce qu'en fait, je n'y suis pas venue du tout naturellement, en fait.
Moi, j'ai été élevée dans une famille où on parlait pas du tout de religion. Enfin, c'était pas du tout une famille de militants ni de...
Enfin oui, on ne croyait pas en Dieu et voilà, donc on ne parlait pas de Dieu puisqu'il n'existait pas, il n'y avait pas de raison d'en parler, voilà.
C'était plus de l'absence de religion-
Oui, c'est ça. Voilà.
...qu'un athéisme militant.
Exactement. Il n'y avait pas du tout de militance ou quoi que ce soit.
Alors, j'ai commencé et terminé des études de philosophie, mais pas du tout dans l'espoir ou dans l'intention de devenir prof de morale.
Enfin, même si c'est ce que je suis devenue par la suite. Donc, moi, j'ai entamé mes études de philo simplement parce que c'était la seule chose que je me voyais faire pendant quatre ans avec sérieux.
Enfin, je me voyais pas étudier quelque chose qui ne m'aurait pas intéressée, donc la philo m'intéressait. Et évidemment, le débouché royal, quand on fait de la philosophie, c'est prof de morale.
Et moi, je n'en voulais pas au départ. Je voyais pas du tout pourquoi j'aurais été-
C'est ce qui s'impose implicitement.
Oui, voilà, tout à fait.
C'est le débouché, puisque souvent, il n'y a pas de débouché pour ces études-là.
Ou alors, ce sont des débouchés très généralistes où tout ce qui vous est demandé, c'est un diplôme universitaire, peu importe lequel.
Et moi, au départ, je m'étais dit : « Ben voilà, après, si ça tombe, j'irai travailler dans une banque parce qu'on aura besoin de quelqu'un qui a un diplôme universitaire, mais j'aurais fait des études qui me plaisent », quoi.
C'est ça.
Et puis bon, j'ai fait quand même l'agrégation pour me dire : « Ben voilà, c'est une corde de plus à mon arc-
Mmh.
...ce serait vraiment trop bête de me,
de me priver de cette possibilité-là ». Et l'enseignement m'a plu, donc je suis devenue prof de morale, mais toujours pas avec l'idée de transmettre des valeurs laïques, parce que c'est quand même ça votre question de départ, quoi.
Oui, tout à fait. Mais professeur de morale, alors, à ce moment-là, dans le secondaire ?
Oui, très vite dans le secondaire. Enfin, mon premier boulot, ça a quand même été prof, enfin maître, maîtresse de morale dans l'enseignement primaire.
Ça, c'était quand même un fameux choc pour moi de sortir de deuxième licence. À l'époque, on appelait ça une deuxième licence
à l'ULB, puis de me retrouver avec des gamins qui, pour certains, ne savaient pas encore écrire, enfin...
Contre votre volonté, d'après ce que vous dites.
Pas contre ma volonté, non, parce qu'entre-temps-
C'était pas votre objectif principal, en tout cas-
Non, mais en faisant l'agrégation, je me suis rendu compte que j'aimais enseigner.
D'accord.
Donc c'est devenu un vrai choix, quand même, l'enseignement. Par contre, je ne me voyais toujours pas enseigner les valeurs laïques.
Enfin, pour moi, l'enseignement, le cours de morale, ça devait être un cours de philo, quoi. Donc c'était ça mon objectif, finalement, c'était d'enseigner la philosophie.
Donc, on est toujours très très loin de la laïcité. Et puis, en fait, ce qui m'a amenée à la laïcité, c'est la monarchie.
La monarchie.
En fait.
C'est également un sujet sur lequel on aura l'occasion de revenir.
C'est pas du tout la philosophie, c'est pas du tout l'enseignement, c'est la monarchie puisque... Et là, il faut que je remonte à l'époque du mariage de Philippe et Mathilde.
Notre roi et notre reine.
Là, on est en 2000, je-- non, en 1999, fin 1999, décembre 99.
Dans ces eaux-là, oui.
Oui, c'est ça. Et là, en fait, moi, je suis exaspérée d'entendre tous les discours... Enfin, le peuple belge entier se réjouit, Philippe et Mathilde vont se marier, c'est la liesse populaire.
Et moi, ça me gonfle vraiment. Je vois pas ce qu'il y a de réjouissant. Mais bon, voilà, c'est un non-événement, quoi.
Il y a un monsieur qui a trouvé une madame et ils sont très contents et tant mieux pour eux. Mais, enfin, le bombardement, je dirais, médiatique auquel on est soumis m'exaspère au plus haut point.
Et donc un soir de Nouvel An, donc dans un contexte qu'on peut imaginer un peu arrosé quand même-
Mh.
...on est quelques-uns et on se dit : « On va faire un cercle républicain ».
D'accord.
On va dire : « Nous, on se réjouit pas. Nous, on s'en fout. Et parce que nous, on trouve que la monarchie, c'est un truc désuet, dépassé.
Et il est temps qu'on sache en Belgique qu'il n'y a pas que des gens qui trouvent ça formidable. »
Et donc, ce cercle républicain, donc ça s'est fait ici, à l'ULB ?
Pas du tout à l'ULB. Non, non, non, non, non. C'était dans le cadre tout à fait privé. Moi, j'étais déjà, j'avais fini mes études depuis plusieurs années.
D'accord.
Non, non, c'est vraiment une bande de copains, quoi. Au départ, c'est un gag, en fait, hein. Il faut comprendre ça, sinon on comprend rien, quoi.
Au départ, c'est un gag. On est cinq, on se dit : « Allez, on va sortir un communiqué de presse pour dire : voilà, nous, on s'en fout de Philippe et Mathilde et la monarchie.
On trouve que c'est quelque chose de complètement archaïque, démodé et anti-démocratique. »
Alors, ça a fait plouf ou bien est-ce que ça a pris ?
Ça a pas du tout fait plouf. Non, au contraire, ça a fa-- alors, ça aurait pu faire plouf parce qu'en fait, très vite, on s'est rendu compte que si on voulait,
que notre cercle soit plus qu'un simple gag, il fallait qu'on ait une adresse postale, il fallait qu'on soit une ASBL.
Or, on ne voulait pas donner notre adresse privée, donc il fallait, pour qu'on puisse avoir une adresse postale, une boîte postale, il fallait qu'on soit une ASBL.
Vous allez vraiment dans le détail, mais ça
Vous m'avez dit que j'avais le temps donc
On a le temps
Et donc bref, on fait cette ASBL et très vite, on commence à avoir des membres.
D'accord. Qui viennent suite à un recrutement, suite à un intérêt spontané ?
Suite à l'un ou l'autre article dans la presse, je crois-
D'accord
...qui relaie la fondation du Cercle républicain. Et donc, on commence à avoir des membres. Sur ces entrefaites, j'abrège quand même un petit peu pour-
Mmh
...pour revenir à la laïcité. On arrive en 2003. Donc là, ça fait trois ans que le Cercle républicain existe. Et 2003, c'est aussi les 10 ans d'anniversaire, si je puis dire, de la mort du roi Baudouin.
Mmh.
Et à cette occasion-là, une maison d'édition veut publier un livre sur Baudouin, mais qui ne soit pas une hagiographie de Baudouin, qui soit un retour critique sur le règne de Baudouin.
Et elle s'adresse pour ça à Claude Javeau, professeur de l'ULB, professeur de sociologie, républicain bien connu, sociologue, etc.
Et lui, il n'a pas le temps, mais il est membre du Cercle républicain. Et donc, il dit : « Bah peut-être que Nadia Geerts, ça l'intéressera ».
Et donc moi qui n'ai jamais écrit aucun livre de ma vie, je me retrouve avec ce truc, cette proposition que je trouve quand même vachement alléchante.
Je me dis : « Waouh ! Moi, j'ai toujours aimé écrire ». Bon, je trouve le projet intéressant et donc je me dis : « Bah oui, allez chiche, je vais faire un bouquin sur Baudouin ».
J'écris donc ce premier livre qui s'appelle « Baudouin sans auréole ».
Et en me documentant sur tous les aspects du règne de Baudouin qui sont quand même un petit peu problématiques à mes yeux, je tombe évidemment sur le gros os qu'est la religiosité omniprésente
Bien sûr, oui
...dans le règne de Baudouin.
Oui. Pour les auditeurs qui seraient peut-être français, on peut par exemple donner comme exemple le fait que le roi Baudouin a refusé de signer la loi concernant-
La dépénalisation de l'avortement
C'est ça. Le-
Oui
...tout ce qui concerne l'avortement, il était pas trop fan, justement pour des raisons religieuses. Et donc, oui, c'est là qu'on observe une intersection entre la religion catholique, la législation, le,
la tête de l'État.
Oui
...voilà, et c'est donc par ce chemin-là que vous êtes arrivée sur le-
Sur la laïcité, c'est ça. En fait, c'est là que je me suis rendu compte tout d'un coup, enfin, tout d'un coup, disons, que j'ai pris conscience du caractère quand même énorme du problème.
'Fin, je me suis dit : « Voilà, effectivement, la Belgique n'est pas un État laïque. Elle a à sa tête un roi qui était ouvertement catholique, n'a pas été capable de faire,
de faire prévaloir son rôle de chef de l'État sur ses convictions religieuses privées.
Et il y a là un vrai problème. » Voilà.
Vous dites en toute simplicité : « La Belgique n'est pas un État laïque ». C'est un statement, une affirmation-
Mmh
...un petit peu controversée, parce que-
Oui, c'est vrai
...certains partagent tout à fait votre avis, d'autres pas du tout.
Mmh.
On va revenir sur autre chose, mais déjà, ce qui me frappe dans ce que vous dites, c'est que quand vous cherchez donc les sources de votre passion, de votre militantisme,
même le, son origine première, à savoir le mariage de Philippe et Mathilde, vous ne savez pas très bien dire pourquoi ça vous a énervée.
C'est parce que plein de gens étaient tout à fait favorables, 'fin tout à fait sympathiques à cet événement.
Vous, ça vous a énervée, mais vous n'avez pas l'air de vraiment savoir pourquoi.
Si, je pense qu'il y a plusieurs aspects. Y a d'abord le rôle de la radio publique, en l'occurrence, puisque c'était-- moi, je m'informais à la RTBF.
'Fin, c'est toujours la radio que j'ai dans ma salle de bain et j'écoute le matin, voilà. 'Fin, et comme beaucoup de gens, je crois.
Et donc ça m'agaçait qu'une radio publique joue aussi peu son rôle de décodeur critique de l'information.
C'est-à-dire qu'on était vraiment dans un truc de liesse populaire, de-
Il y avait une hégémonie, il y avait-
Oui
...une affirmation comme quoi c'était le, un establishment, une institution qu'on ne remettait pas en question.
Oui, c'est ça. Voilà, c'était merveilleux. Tout le monde se réunissait-
C'est ça
...se réjouissait, c'était des micro-trottoirs, c'était... 'Fin, c'était de la non-information.
Mmh.
Donc ça, c'est un des volets. Et l'autre volet, c'était le fait que je me dis : « Bah tant qu'à...»
'Fin, c'est lié, évidemment. « Tant qu'à parler de monarchie, ben parlons alors de ses fondements juridiques, d'où elle trouve sa source, sa légitimité.
» 'Fin, je sais pas, 'fin qu'on ait un regard critique sur l'institution plutôt que d'être dans le carnet mondain, quoi.
C'est ça.
En fait, c'est ça.
Donc c'est une approche, finalement, du libre examen, quoi. C'est-
Oui
...remettre en question-
Oui, oui, tout à fait. Oui, oui
...une espèce d'évidence que certains-
Oui
...voilà-
Oui, et c'était le fait d'être associée aussi, malgré moi. Parce qu'en fait, ce que la radio publique présentait à l'époque, c'était une image d'un peuple belge unanimement heureux.
Et moi, j'avais envie de dire : « Mais en fait, y a des gens qui s'en foutent ». Moi, je ne me sens pas représentée par ma radio publique quand elle dit qu'on est tous contents. Ça n'est pas vrai.
Donc, vous dites que suite à la création de ce Cercle républicain-
Oui
...vous avez été rejoint par de plus en plus de monde.
Mmh.
La question que j'ai envie de poser, c'est : quel est le profil des gens qui vous rejoignent à ce moment-là ? Est-ce qu'on observe une provenance de certains partis politiques, certaines régions, certaines-
Alors, y a toujours eu très peu de politiques. Y en a eu quelques-uns, mais qui étaient plutôt, je dirais, des francs-tireurs.
'Fin, je pense à quelqu'un comme Josy Dubié, par exemple, qui était un militant écolo de longue date, qui a toujours été républicain, qui n'en a jamais fait mystère.
Ou Jean-Marie Dermagne, par exemple, avocat, bâtonnier. Enfin bon, homme de gauche encore actif aujourd'hui.
Mais ce sont plutôt des exceptions. Alors,
notre spécificité au Cercle républicain, c'est qu'on voulait vraiment dissocier le débat sur la République ou sur la monarchie, si on veut, de toutes les autres questions politiques qui pouvaient se poser.
C'est-à-dire qu'on ne prenait pas parti pour une forme particulière d'avenir de l'État belge. Parce qu'évidemment, c'est la question qui se pose tout de suite, évidemment-
C'est ça.
...c'est si on supprime la monarchie, qu'est-ce qu'on fait de la Belgique ?
Voilà.
Est-ce qu'elle reste unie ? Est-ce qu'elle se divise ? Est-ce qu'on est pour une Flandre indépendante, pour une République unie, à la Suisse, à la française, à l'américaine-
Ouais.
...etc., etc. Et donc nous, on voulait vraiment-
Être le plus inclusif possible à ce niveau-là.
Oui, voilà, exactement. Donc se contenter de dire : « Voilà, nous sommes convaincus tous ici présents en tant que membres du Cercle républicain
du fait que la monarchie n'est pas en adéquation avec les valeurs démocratiques modernes, et qu'il est possible de trouver une autre forme d'organisation pour la Belgique ».
Après, chacun est libre et donc il y avait parmi les membres du Cercle républicain des gens qui étaient clairement séparatistes, y avait des gens qui étaient pour le rassemblement avec la France, par exemple.
Y avait des gens qui étaient ce qu'on appelle des Belgiquins, quoi. Quelqu'un comme Josy Dubié était quelqu'un qui était très attaché à la pérennité de la Belgique, mais comme une République, une République de Belgique.
Et tout ça faisait bon ménage, en fait. Tiens, moi, c'est ce que j'ai trouvé vraiment intéressant dans cette,
dans cette expérience, c'est de voir qu'on était capables
de comprendre qu'on se rassemblait sur quelque chose et qu'on pouvait par ailleurs
défendre des thèses complètement opposées dans d'autres cercles, parce que certains étaient engagés dans des partis politiques, par exemple, qui
qui prônaient le, oui, le séparatisme ou le rattachement à la France, par exemple.
Mais ils savaient très bien que c'était pas au Cercle républicain qu'ils devaient arriver avec ça. On n'était pas là pour ça, nous.
C'est ça. Donc un but précis qui, du coup-
Oui, oui.
...peut rassembler beaucoup de monde.
On va revenir un instant sur la laïcité. Voilà, on va reprendre les bases puisque voilà, c'est un sujet que vous connaissez très bien, mais peut-être que certains de nos auditeurs ne se sont jamais vraiment posé la question, au fond,
de la laïcité en Belgique.
Vous l'avez dit, il y a un instant, vous estimez que la Belgique n'est pas un État laïque. Pourtant, aux yeux du néophyte, il y a bien une certaine séparation entre le législateur et l'Église, entre le gouvernement et l'Église.
Qu'est-ce qui vous amène à dire aussi catégoriquement : « La Belgique n'est pas un État laïque » ?
Ben alors d'abord, c'est une réponse un peu bête et méchante que je vais vous faire, c'est que c'est pas un État laïque parce que c'est écrit nulle part. Voilà.
Oui.
Dans la Constitution, dans la Constitution belge, il est dit simplement que la Belgique est neutre, mais il n'est pas dit qu'elle est laïque.
Certains vous rétorqueront alors, et je sais que certains l'ont fait, qu'il n'est pas écrit explicitement qu'elle est une démocratie non plus.
Non, c'est vrai, mais... C'est vrai, c'est une colle. Mais disons qu'y a quand même une réponse un peu moins bête et méchante.
C'est qu'en plus, il me semble qu'il y a encore aujourd'hui, dans la manière dont la Belgique fonctionne, des choses qui ne seraient pas envisageables dans un État qui serait vraiment laïque.
Quand vous dites vraiment laïque, vous prenez généralement comme référence...
La France.
Oui. Autant la France ne me semble pas être un modèle en matière de République, je pense qu'y a plus intéressant que la France,
autant en matière de laïcité, c'est vrai que ma référence, ça reste quand même la France, en tout cas en tant que modèle théorique.
Modèle théorique, oui.
Mais oui, parce que je pense que, bon, je crois que si on discute avec des Français, ils vous diront à quel point la laïcité a pu être malmenée, ces dernières décennies.
Mm-hmm.
Et parfois, il y a effectivement des violations flagrantes du principe de laïcité-
Le département de-
L'Alsace-Moselle, par exemple.
C'est ça. Oui, que là, c'est-
Voilà, c'est... Ben oui, c'est quand même énorme, ça, quand même, qu'on continue à financer le culte dans deux départements français,
et que jusqu'à présent, on n'ait toujours pas remis cette espèce d'entorse en question-
Mm-hmm.
...c'est quand même quelque chose d'assez-
Donc vous mettez en opposition donc cette laïcité théorique-
Mm-hmm.
...française-
Oui.
...avec, voilà, quelques problèmes dans la pratique, mais le modèle, vous l'admirez.
Oui, oui.
Vous mettez en opposition à ce modèle de laïcité, ce qu'on appelle régulièrement la neutralité à la belge.
Voilà, oui. La neutralité qui, justement, par exemple, permet le financement des cultes ou le financement d'un enseignement confessionnel ou l'organisation de cours de religion au sein des écoles officielles.
Ça, c'est vraiment pour moi des exemples de choses qui ne sont pas compatibles avec l'idée de la laïcité.
Si on part de l'idée que la laïcité, c'est la séparation entre le politique et le religieux, ben,
l'enseignement, pour prendre cet exemple-là, à partir du moment où c'est un enseignement officiel, public, donc organisé par l'État ou par une de ses composantes, devrait être complètement séparé du religieux.
Or, en Belgique, ce n'est pas le cas.
Mm-hmm.
On a un enseignement confessionnel-
Oui.
...qui est largement subventionné et on a des cours de religion dans les écoles officielles.
Et l'enseignement libre confessionnel est même dominant-
Tout à fait, oui, il est majoritaire.
C'est 60 % des écoles secondaires-
Oui.
...des élèves en école secondaire en Francophonie et en région flamande, c'est même-
C'est même un peu plus. Oui, je pense.
...deux tiers.
Je connais pas les chiffres exacts, mais c'est en tout cas un enseignement qui est majoritaire, effectivement, oui, oui.
C'est effectivement ça qui frappe avec la Belgique, c'est que dans-
Mm.
...ces institutions publiques, et pas seulement les écoles, puisque y a aussi les hôpitaux, la mutualité chrétienne également, le plus important, ça reste l'école, une institution très intéressante à ce niveau-là.
Avant de nous pencher sur ce qui fait,
voilà, ce qui pose problème avec cette
chrétienté assumée de toutes ces institutions, j'ai finalement envie de poser la question de savoir : mais qu'est-ce qui reste réellement du catholicisme dans toutes ces institutions ?
Je me rappelle avoir vu, par exemple, il y a quelques années, un fait d'actualité autour d'un professeur de philosophie à l'UCL qui était ouvertement contre l'avortement et qui estimait que c'était immoral d'avorter, voilà.
Position qui est finalement complètement alignée sur la vision catholique traditionnelle, voilà, qu'on n'est pas, qui n'est pas rare d'entendre ici-
Ouais.
...en Belgique. Et pourtant, voilà, ce professeur s'est rapidement fait virer, comme quoi ça n'était pas du tout aligné sur les valeurs de l'Université catholique de Louvain.
Je me souviens qu'en lisant ce fait d'actualité, j'étais sérieusement surpris et je m'interrogeais très sérieusement pour savoir : mais finalement, qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Parce qu'on m'avait répondu : oui, non, l'Université catholique de Louvain n'est pas aux ordres du Saint-Siège, elle a un héritage catholique.
Mais personne ne savait vraiment m'expliquer ce que c'est un héritage catholique.
Oui oui, c'est ce que dans l'enseignement catholique, on appelle souvent le pluralisme situé, ce qui moi me fait bien rire, je trouve l'expression assez extraordinairement bien trouvée.
C'est une façon de dire finalement, on est pluraliste, donc on est ouvert à tous les points de vue, mais on est quand même situé.
Donc on part d'une autre-
Mmh.
...mais on va vers les autres points de vue, mais sans renoncer aux nôtres quand même. Donc c'est très chèvrechoutiste ou très jésuite, je trouve.
Mais vous avez raison, je pense que le poids de la religion catholique est très variable en fait en fonction des écoles, par exemple, où on se situe. C'est clair que,
si on fait un petit topo des écoles catholiques
aujourd'hui, ben il y a évidemment un monde de différence entre la présence de la religion catholique dans une école catholique au cœur de Molenbeek ou de Saint-Josse et la présence de la religion catholique à Arlon-
Mmh.
...dans une école confessionnelle à Arlon. Parce qu'évidemment, il y a des écoles catholiques aujourd'hui qui ne sont plus fréquentées majoritairement par des petits catholiques, loin de là.
Le public, la démographie change, en particulier à Bruxelles. Et donc on sait bien aujourd'hui qu'à Molenbeek ou à Saint-Josse, pour reprendre ces deux exemples-là, ben la plupart des enfants sont plutôt des petits musulmans-
Mmh.
...même s'ils fréquentent une école catholique. Donc nécessairement, évidemment, ça impose à l'école catholique, si elle veut garder son public-
Une certaine flexibilité.
...de s'ouvrir, d'arrêter de tenir un discours qui soit un discours trop ouvertement catholique.
Donc ça va être un discours beaucoup plus œcuménique, de dire : voilà, au fond, on partage pour l'essentiel les mêmes convictions, la même religion, etc.
Et donc on va trouver des cours de religion soi-disant catholiques qui sont en fait plutôt des cours de religions au pluriel, où on va comparer les traditions islamiques et catholiques, par exemple.
J'ai même eu un cours de religion, parce que moi, je proviens moi-même de, je suis moi-même issu de l'enseignement libre confessionnel ici, ici à Bruxelles.
Effectivement, en cours de religion, on lisait des Amin Maalouf, on lisait des philosophes français ou autres.
Oui, oui.
Mais oui, donc je pense qu'effectivement, ça peut être très variable.
Je suis persuadée que certaines écoles catholiques peuvent se permettre d'être encore aujourd'hui plus clairement et plus ouvertement catholiques parce qu'on y cultive encore
davantage l'entre-soi que dans d'autres écoles, parce que c'est encore possible de par la situation géographique de ces écoles-là.
Donc, je pense qu'il y a une grande variabilité. Mais ce qui reste quand même, me semble-t-il, c'est une méconnaissance ou, comment dire, l'évidence de la foi.
Ce que je veux dire par là, c'est que moi, c'est quelque chose qui me frappe,
en tant qu'enseignante, puisque maintenant, j'enseigne en haute école, donc je vois arriver des élèves qui sortent, 'fin des étudiants qui sortent du secondaire.
Les produits de l'enseignement catholique.
Ben les produits de l'enseignement catholique et de l'enseignement officiel-
Oui, oui, tout à fait.
...tout confondu.
Du coup, vous savez les différencier.
Voilà. Et y a quand même quelque chose qui me frappe, c'est que souvent, j'ai l'impression que les enfants, 'fin les enfants qui sont devenus adultes, mais les étudiants qui sortent de l'enseignement libre confessionnel
ont une méconnaissance totale
du fait athée.
L'athéisme, ils connaissent pas.
Mmh.
Ils en ont jamais ou très peu entendu parler. Il y a une espèce d'évidence comme ça que ben oui, tout le monde croit en Dieu, quoi.
Peut-être pas nécessairement le même.
C'est un décalage important par rapport à mon expérience personnelle, puisque moi-même-
Ouais.
...donc, je peux raconter ma vie l'espace d'un instant- ...mais donc l'école secondaire où j'étais allé, il y avait d'une part, donc, des profs de religion qui étaient des sœurs, 'fin une sœur de l'ordre des Annonciades.
On avait un prof de religion qui était aussi le prof de sciences. Ça, c'était très intéressant.
Mmh.
J'avais une prof de religion qui m'expliquait, de manière même pas très subtile, que l'homosexualité n'était pas très naturelle.
Et à côté de ça, j'avais des profs qui m'expliquaient qu'ils voulaient se faire débaptiser. J'avais très très peu de camarades ouvertement catholiques et qui avaient soit une absence de religion, soit un athéisme affirmé même pour certains.
Donc, je suis surpris. Vous avez l'air de dire que dans votre expérience-
Mh, mh. Ouais.
...les deux ne sont pas impossibles puisque finalement, mon école n'était peut-être pas représentative de ce qu'on voit en général, mais vous avez l'air de dire que ça produit littéralement des bons chrétiens.
Non, c'est pas ça que j'ai voulu dire.
Disons que j'ai l'impression que le message dominant, encore aujourd'hui, qui est véhiculé par l'enseignement confessionnel, c'est qu'au fond, peu importe quel est le Dieu qu'on a, du moment qu'on en a un.
C'est ça. C'est une évidence que-
Oui, et que donc il y a une espèce de blackout qui est fait sur le fait que certains puissent ne pas en avoir, de Dieu.
C'est vrai que ce n'est pas un sujet qui est abordé explicitement, parce que même quand on lisait les philosophes marocains en cours de religion,
il y avait généralement, ça tournait généralement autour du pot, autour de Dieu.
Oui.
C'est... Ouais, c'est pas faux, oui. Je crois que vous touchez à quelque chose d'intéressant.
Alors, y a ça et alors il y a aussi autre chose, je pense, c'est que j'ai l'impression qu'il y a un esprit chrétien très relié au fait de ne pas faire de vagues, ne pas choquer, être consensuel.
D'accord.
Oui, c'est ça. Ça, je trouve que c'est quand même un esprit. C'est pas au niveau, c'est pas des dogmes qui sont transmis ou des choses comme ça.
C'est plutôt une volonté de ne pas choquer, de ne pas ruer dans les brancards, de consensualisme.
Ça m'avait frappée, par exemple, parce que j'ai... Donc aujourd'hui, j'enseigne notamment la neutralité. On aura peut-être l'occasion d'y revenir plus tard.
Mh, mh.
Et en fait, donc c'est un cours qui a été rendu obligatoire en 2003 pour tous les futurs enseignants. Et du coup, les universités ont dû évidemment mettre en place un cours de neutralité que je suis allée suivre à l'UCL.
D'abord parce que c'était la première université qui a été prête à le mettre en place, et ensuite parce que j'étais curieuse de voir ce que l'UCL allait faire-
Mmm
...de la neutralité.
Alors, qu'est-ce que-
Je trouvais ça intéressant.
Qu'est-ce que vous avez vu là-bas ?
J'ai pas vu grand-chose en fait. C'est-à-dire que j'ai vu— alors c'était la première année, il s'agit pas du tout ici de faire le procès de l'UCL hein, mais c'était des cours du-
donc ils donnaient le samedi matin et donc on avait un premier samedi qui était
la neutralité du point de vue juridique et puis le samedi suivant, la neutralité d'un point de vue philosophique, troisième samedi, la neutralité d'un point de vue historique, etc., etc.
Finalement, le cours lui-même n'avait pas de point de vue, c'était une variété-
Voilà, exactement. Voilà, c'était des exposés ex cathedra sur donc des éclairages différents sur la neutralité.
Mais à aucun moment, on n'a eu de débat, de discussion sur ce que c'était la neutralité concrètement à l'école, parce que c'est quand même pour ça qu'on était là, hein, normalement.
Ça se place finalement dans ce— alors, je crois que c'est surtout dans l'école catholique flamande, ce qu'ils appellent l'école du dialogue.
Avec des gros guillemets, si vous voulez.
Oui, oui.
Mais c'est comme ça qu'ils l'appellent. Où ils— voilà, où il y a l'idée de rencontrer le point de vue de l'autre.
Oui, sauf que je trouve que justement, il y a pas de dialogue.
Rencontrer le point de vue de l'autre à travers des livres, mais pas à travers des-
Oui, voilà, exactement. Voilà, et moi, c'est vrai que j'aime le débat, j'aime la discussion-
Mmm
...et la controverse ne me fait pas peur. Enfin, je trouve que c'est intéressant de pouvoir discuter, même éventuellement se disputer, 'fin, de manière intelligente.
Évidemment, il s'agit pas d'en venir aux mains ou de se balancer des assiettes à la tête hein, mais, 'fin, j'ai pas peur d'un échange un peu vif.
Je trouve que beaucoup de choses peuvent sortir de ce genre de controverse. Et j'ai l'impression que ça, c'est quand même une tradition très liée au libre examen, en fait.
Oui, complètement.
Et qu'on retrouve ça beaucoup moins dans l'enseignement confessionnel.
Ce qui me vient immédiatement à l'esprit quand vous dites ça, c'est
l'événement qui a marqué l'histoire de l'enseignement catholique en Belgique, à savoir Vatican II, quand un enseignement où c'était littéralement des frères, 'fin, oui, des frères et des sœurs au sens-
Oui, oui
...au sens clérical du terme, où voilà, où l'éducation sexuelle était, par exemple, soit pas donnée du tout, soit donnée par une sœur, de manière— ...de la manière dont-
Qui connaissait certainement énormément la matière.
C'est ça. OK, c'est ça.
Oui.
C'est bien résumé. Et puis Vatican II a, voilà, un petit peu tout changé et il y a eu une grosse laïcisation de tous ces établissements.
Mais d'après ce que j'ai pu lire, il y a eu quand même une certaine conservation de l'héritage, du message, du fonctionnement de ces établissements.
Forcément, le— bon, on va pas faire tout un discours, même si c'est très intéressant, sur la place de la femme dans l'Église catholique et dans tout ce que ça implique.
Mais un enseignement catholique est forcément un enseignement dogmatique. Et donc,
ce que vous dites, finalement, comme quoi vous voyez dans le— dans les élèves qui sont produits par cet enseignement, vous y voyez des traces de,
de dogmatisme, de dogme.
Mmm-hmm.
Plus qu'un attrait pour le dialogue et le libre examen. Ça a finalement beaucoup de sens.
Oui, il me semble, oui. Enfin, en tout cas, moi, c'est ma perception des choses. Oui-
Mais donc, on en parlait de,
des écoles. Maintenant, c'est— voilà, je pose la question parce que même en tant que Belge qui
vit— moi, je suis Bruxellois, je côtoie toutes ces institutions depuis un bon bout de temps maintenant, je ne comprends toujours pas très bien, et je la sens,
je sens qu'elle est là, mais je ne sais pas mettre un mot dessus.
La différence entre, par exemple, un hôpital ouvertement catholique comme Saint-Luc et un hôpital ouvertement laïque comme Erasme.
Quelle est la différence dans un hôpital, un lieu de soins, de soins publics, entre un hôpital catholique et un hôpital laïque ?
Alors, je dirais que la différence— 'fin, pour répondre à votre question, j'ai envie d'introduire une notion qui me paraît fondamentale si on veut comprendre la Belgique, qui est la notion de pilarisation.
La pilarisation, c'est-à-dire qu'en fait, la société belge est une société qui a toujours été constituée en piliers.
Piliers qui étaient des piliers politico-religieux. C'est-à-dire qu'en Belgique, il a longtemps été possible, et c'est encore possible,
de naître dans une famille socialiste et donc dans un hôpital socialiste, d'être du coup, d'aller dans une école du giron socialiste.
À la mutualité socialiste.
D'être à la mutualité socialiste, d'être soigné dans des hôpitaux affiliés ou adossés à la mutualité socialiste et de mourir en bon socialiste.
Donc en fait, on avait une espèce de chemin tout tracé, hein, un pilier dans lequel on pouvait naître, grandir, mourir.
Même chose si on était catholique, on avait la mutualité chrétienne, 'fin, le baptême, les écoles catholiques, les hôpitaux catholiques, l'enterrement religieux, etc., etc.
Ce qui du coup favorise, oui, l'entre-soi, le-
Voilà, exactement.
La diminution du dialogue.
Voilà, et donc ces piliers, ça veut aussi dire que les hôpitaux, 'fin, les hôpitaux, quels qu'ils soient d'ailleurs, sont en fait adossés à des universités et que-
Oui
...il y a un privilège-
Pour Saint-Luc, c'est l'université catholique de Louvain et pour Erasme-
Voilà
...c'est l'université libre de Bruxelles.
Voilà, exactement.
Libre-penseurs, francs-maçons, etc.
Voilà, exactement. Et donc il y a une espèce de— 'fin, je pense, alors c'est sans doute moins comme ça aujourd'hui que ça n'était le cas il y a cinquante ans,
mais je pense que chaque hôpital considère encore aujourd'hui les universités comme une espèce de vivier dans lesquelles elles vont pouvoir aller puiser leurs médecins, leur personnel soignant, etc., etc.
Ce personnel ayant évidemment reçu une formation qui n'est quand même pas totalement la même d'un point de vue-
Idéologique, oui, c'est ça.
Voilà. Donc, de là à dire que dans les hôpitaux catholiques, on ne fait pas d'avortement ni d'euthanasie, c'est faux. Je veux dire, ça se pratique aussi, mais il y a quand même des tendances lourdes.
Comme ?
Comme le fait que, voilà, que moi, personnellement, je sais que si un jour, je dois être hospitalisée et qu'il y a un risque vital, je n'irai pas dans un, dans une, un-
Un hôpital catholique parce que je craindrais à un moment donné de me retrouver...
Je pense que le risque est plus grand de me retrouver face à un personnel qui soit moins à l'écoute de mes désirs en la matière.
D'accord.
Voilà. Ça n'est pas une règle absolue. Je ne dirais-
Mmh.
Certainement pas à Saint-Luc, je ne serais pas euthanasiée, par exemple, mais par contre, je pense que le risque-
Il y a des chances.
Est plus grand qu'à Saint-Luc, ce soit plus difficile pour moi ou pour mes proches d'obtenir mon euthanasie-
C'est ça.
Si c'est ce que j'ai toujours voulu et affirmé, etc., etc. C'est tout. Enfin, c'est tout et c'est beaucoup.
Oui, non, mais c'est vraiment— C'est pas un message ouvertement catholique ou quoi, mais c'est dans le, voilà, dans la subtilité.
Ce qui me frappe moi également, c'est dans les décorations sur les murs, on voit toujours des illustrations très, très familiales, très hétérocentrées, la maman avec ses enfants, etc.
Donc, il y a quelque chose d'assez intangible. Enfin, moi, je pense-
Oui, oui, mais je crois qu'il y a aussi cette idée de ne pas choquer quoi. C'est pourquoi les... Enfin, j'imagine que
ce n'est pas parce qu'on est catholique qu'on est homophobe hein, mais je pense que simplement, les gens qui décident de ce qu'on va mettre au mur se disent : « Bon, allez, si on mettait
deux hommes ou deux femmes, ça pourrait choquer une partie de notre public.
Donc, quel est l'intérêt ? Restons-en à des choses très,
très consensuelles quoi, qui ne choqueront pas. » Alors voilà, ça peut avoir son intérêt à certains moments et je pense qu'à d'autres moments, parfois, c'est peut-être utile d'être un peu plus rentre-dedans quoi.
On va revenir sur ce que vous disiez sur la laïcité hein, pour se recentrer sur ce sujet qui sera, voilà, le fil rouge-
Mmh.
De cette discussion. Il y a donc, d'après ce que j'ai pu lire, d'après ce que j'ai pu comprendre, d'après ce que j'ai pu entendre, deux visions de la laïcité pour un même mot, deux sens qui lui sont accordés.
On a d'un côté ce que certains appellent la laïcité comme étant un outil politique, un instrument-
Mmh.
Politique-
Oui.
De séparation entre l'État et l'Église.
Mmh.
D'éviter de morceler la population, d'être finalement... Fermer les yeux sur tout ce qui peut distinguer, tant en termes religieux, raciaux-
Et socio-économiques, etc. Puis de l'autre côté, on a la laïcité qui est peut-être plus la vôtre, que certains appellent la laïcité philosophique.
On va revenir sur ce terme-
Mmh.
Éventuellement, si vous voulez corriger ou vous estimez que,
je ne vais pas parler à votre place, mais vous estimez par exemple que cette laïcité implique, par exemple, le féminisme, elle implique l'antiracisme, qu'il y a également, qu'elle implique également
un certain anticléricalisme.
Oui.
Ce qui, finalement, est plus dans l'idéologie et moins dans la neutralité, si je comprends bien.
Non. Alors, je suis pas d'accord du tout, mais c'est pas grave.
Ah mais je pensais vous citer, mais bon c'est-
Non.
Heureusement, vous êtes là.
C'est-à-dire, vous avez raison sur à peu près tout. Sauf que, et c'est un point important, pour moi, c'est bien de la laïcité politique que découle le féminisme et l'antiracisme. Donc, en fait,
ce que vous esquissiez comme,
comme distinction, c'est donc la distinction entre une laïcité politique qui serait donc le,
la défense d'un principe de séparation des Églises et de l'État et d'autre part, ce qu'on appelle souvent en Belgique, je crois, enfin, je crois que c'est à ça que vous faisiez allusion,
la laïcité philosophique-
Mmh.
Qui est en fait une autre façon de nommer l'athéisme.
OK. Ça, c'est intéressant parce que c'est à ça que je voulais arriver.
OK, d'accord.
Donc, mais est-ce que c'est complètement assumé, cette équivalence que vous présentez entre l'athéisme et la laïcité philosophique, comme par exemple au sein du Centre d'action laïque, sur lequel on aura également l'occasion de revenir.
Est-ce que finalement, le Centre d'action laïque n'est autre qu'un centre pour athées ?
Je dirais que oui et non. C'est-à-dire que
je pense que la démarche du Centre d'action laïque a consisté historiquement à dire : « Au fond, puisque,
les cultes bénéficient d'un financement de l'État, par souci d'égalité, il est important que ceux qui ne se reconnaissent dans aucun de ces cultes aient, eux aussi, un organe de représentation. »
Mmh.
Donc c'est, si vous voulez, c'est au nom de la laïcité politique, c'est-à-dire du principe d'impartialité de l'État, que les laïques ont exigé et obtenu la constitution d'un organe qui représente en fait ceux qui n'ont pas de religion.
C'est ça.
Donc c'est un peu compliqué-
Oui.
À articuler-
Mais ça me paraît en fait logique. C'est-à-dire que c'est le souci de rétablir une égalité entre les citoyens qui n'aurait pas existé sans l'existence du CAL.
C'est ça.
En fait.
Oui, mais donc il y a une, je crois, une ambiguïté pour beaucoup de personnes.
Ah oui. Du coup, c'est vrai qu'il y a une ambiguïté parce que le Centre d'action laïque défend, je dirais, un principe de laïcité politique qui, mais enfin, comment dire ?
Je pense que l'ambiguïté, elle n'est pas dans le CAL. Enfin, alors, l'ambiguïté du CAL, on pourra revenir par ailleurs-
Oui, bien sûr.
Mais je pense que l'ambiguïté, elle est plus fondamentale que ça. C'est en fait, elle est liée au fait que,
il est évidemment beaucoup plus facile de défendre un principe de séparation des Églises et de l'État si on n'est pas croyant.
Bien sûr.
Je veux dire, ça, c'est une généralité.
Mmh.
Je veux dire, ça ne, ça-
Ça vérifie un peu très facilement, oui.
Mais oui, bien sûr que si on est croyant, alors ça ne veut pas dire qu'on ne peut pas être croyant et laïque. Je pense qu'on peut vraiment être croyant et laïque, mais ça implique quand même une démarche de distanciation.
Oui, le militantisme est moins fort.
Moi, je crois... C'est pas une question de militantisme, c'est simplement d'être capable de faire la part des choses entre ses convictions privées et la manière dont un État doit s'organiser.
Et c'est pas évident. Je veux dire, c'est pas évident, par exemple, de se dire : « Tiens, voilà, à titre personnel, je trouve que la vie est un don de Dieu et que donc l'avortement, quelque part, revient à-
Mmh.
À contrevenir à la volonté de Dieu. » Donc ça, ce serait une position de croyant. Mais donc c'est compliqué de partir de ça et d'en arriver à dire : « Au fond, c'est pas une raison pour que l'État interdise le recours à l'avortement. »
Oui. Et ce que vous voulez dire, c'est que cette démarche est beaucoup plus simple à partir du moment où on n'a pas de conviction-
Mais oui, bien sûr.
Religieuse.
Bien sûr. Si on n'est pas croyant, alors à ce moment-là, on voit tout de suite, immédiatement, je dirais, l'intérêt à ce que les lois ne soient pas inspirées par une religion, puisqu'on n'a soi-même pas de religion.
Ce que j'ai trouvé intéressant, c'est que donc quand je vous citais en disant que vous pensez que-
Oui.
...de la laïcité découle, et donc vous me corrigez en disant de la laïcité au sens-
Politique, oui.
...politique, oui, découle le féminisme, l'anticléricalisme-
Oui.
...et j'en ai oublié un.
L'antiracisme.
L'antiracisme, oui, oui. Mais là, je vois quelque chose de très... un paradoxe, puisque beaucoup de religions ne sont pas du tout, par exemple, féministes.
Beaucoup de religions ne sont pas du tout anticléricales. Et donc, si la laïcité se veut comme étant un petit peu l'instrument d'organisation pour participer à l'harmonie entre tous ces cultes-
Oui, différentes, oui.
...si on veut qu'elle ferme les yeux sur toutes ces différentes confessions, finalement exprimer une pensée féministe, antiraciste, anticléricale qui finalement s'oppose à ces confessions-là.
Comment est-ce que c'est possible d'être à la fois neutre et à la fois de s'opposer fondamentalement à tout cet héritage patriarcal, clérical et autres ?
Pour moi, il s'agit de s'opposer à ce que l'État prenne parti pour une vision religieuse du monde. Donc dans une vision religieuse du monde, par exemple pour prendre le féminisme,
Dieu a créé les hommes et les femmes dans une perspective bien... et dans un but bien précis.
C'est ça, des rôles genrés bien définis.
Voilà. Donc dans l'esprit de Dieu ou dans l'idée de Dieu, c'est pas pour rien qu'il y a deux sexes.
Mmm-hmm.
Et donc il importe que chacun des sexes se conforme ou se comporte conformément à ce qu'il est attendu de lui.
Mmm.
Donc c'est en fait la notion de complémentarité, tant inventée par les religions, quoi. C'est de dire-
D'accord.
...en gros, les hommes et les femmes sont égaux, mais-
Mais, ouais.
...ils ont des rôles différents. Et donc il importe que l'homme continue à jouer son rôle d'homme et que la femme joue son rôle de femme.
Et le pire, évidemment, c'est si on en vient à tout embrouiller, que les hommes veulent commencer à faire des trucs de femmes et que les femmes veulent faire des trucs de mecs.
Enfin là, ça va plus du tout.
Mmm-hmm.
Donc ça, c'est... je caricature évidemment, mais c'est quand même une vision très imprégnée de référentiel religieux.
Petite parenthèse de deux secondes, mais est-ce que dans les étudiants que vous voyez sortir des écoles catholiques, est-ce que vous voyez justement une affirmation plus forte des rôles genrés ?
Ça, je ne sais pas. Non, j'irais pas jusque-là. Ce qui me paraît certain, par contre, c'est que les étudiants qui sont croyants ont plus de mal avec-
La transsexualité, avec le-
Ou avec l'égalité des sexes conçue comme un refus de tout enfermement dans-
C'est ça.
...des stéréotypes de genre, quoi. Je veux dire, les étudiants croyants sont souvent plus sensibles à la complémentarité.
C'est souvent eux qui vont dire : « Oui, mais enfin quand même, madame, on n'est quand même pas pareil, quoi ».
Mmm-hmm, c'est ça.
Et moi, je dis : « Ben non, évidemment qu'on n'est pas pareil ». La question n'est pas là. La question, c'est : est-ce qu'on a le droit de se définir librement en tant qu'homme ou en tant que femme
sans devoir coller à des obligations dues au fait qu'on est né homme ou né femme ?
Moi, c'est ça la question fondamentale du féminisme. Et le lien avec la laïcité, alors, c'est un lien qui est sans doute, enfin, qui est très, très philosophique dans son approche, hein, mais
l'origine de la laïcité, c'est quand même pour l'État de dire : « Nous n'avons pas à tenir compte des convictions religieuses des uns et des autres ».
Donc quand on établit des lois, ou des règles de fonctionnement de la Cité, il faut les établir en fonction de l'intérêt commun,
donc de l'intérêt général, et pas pour faire plaisir à une catégorie particulière de la population qui aurait des convictions religieuses X, Y ou Z.
Donc dans ce sens-là, l'État va développer une sorte d'indifférence par rapport aux convictions religieuses des uns et des autres, en disant : « Voilà, nous, c'est pas ça qui compte pour nous.
Ce qui compte pour nous, c'est que vous êtes tous des citoyens qu'on doit faire vivre ensemble selon des règles communes ».
Et pour moi, en disant ça, l'État a ouvert une brèche qui ne pouvait que mener à d'autres types d'indifférence, et notamment l'indifférence par rapport au sexe.
Parce que pour l'État, en fait, qu'est-ce que ça peut lui faire qu'on soit homme ou femme ?
Mmm-hmm. C'est ça-
Pour l'État, on est des citoyens-
Un État laïc-
...hommes et femmes, mais on est des citoyens qui-
Un État laïc se comporte et légifère de manière laïque, donc féministe, donc antiraciste, donc anticléricale, mais sans pour autant propager ce genre d'idéologie, sans pour autant-
C'est pas... non, il s'agit pas de propager une idéologie.
C'est ça.
Il s'agit de dire : « Vous êtes croyant, pas croyant, homme, femme, blanc, noir, d'origine ceci ou cela, etc. Tout ça, nous, État, ça ne nous intéresse pas parce que nous n'avons à gérer que des relations entre citoyens ».
Et donc c'est votre commune appartenance de citoyen qui compte.
Et du coup, l'État laïc est forcément anticlérical puisqu'il s'oppose au fait qu'un quelconque clergé, un quelconque pouvoir religieux puisse venir se mêler de faire de la politique.
Puisque l'État laïc va vouloir défendre son indépendance par rapport aux religieux et que le cléricalisme, c'est précisément vouloir se mêler de politique quand on est une puissance religieuse.
Une des particularités de la Belgique, c'est aussi, donc je crois que vous l'avez mentionné, le financement des cultes.
Mmm-hmm.
De certains cultes-
Ouais.
...pas de tous les cultes.
Donc je crois qu'il y en a six ou sept-
Alors, il y en a six, enfin, à strictement parler, hein, donc catholicisme, protestantisme, religion israélite, religion orthodoxe, islam, et anglicanisme.
Oui, plus-
À quoi il faut ajouter la laïcité organisée. Et le financement des cultes, il s'impose à nous. Je veux dire, c'est une part de nos impôts qui est prélevée et qui est redistribuée ensuite par l'État.
Et on ne peut pas dire : « Moi, je veux que mon argent aille à telle communauté ou à telle autre ». Ça marche pas comme ça.
Mmm-hmm.
Et bon, je rappelle quand même toujours que encore aujourd'hui, c'est l'Église catholique qui reçoit à elle seule 85 % du-
C'est ça.
...budget des cultes.
Sur base de critères comme l'intemporalité, le-
Sur-
...participation.
Non, alors, la part du budget, c'est parce que c'est simplement un critère qui n'a jamais été remis en question depuis la période napoléonienne.
D'accord.
Donc voilà, on a... parce qu'on ne fait pas de statistiques non plus d'appartenance.
Et que donc, voilà, on est aujourd'hui encore à 85 % du budget des cultes qui va à l'Église catholique, alors que évidemment, ce n'est un secret pour personne qu'il n'y a plus aujourd'hui 85 % de catholiques pratiquants en Belgique.
J'aimerais revenir sur la distinction que vous avez faite entre le Centre d'action laïque et l'athéisme.
Mmm-hmm. Oui.
Dans le discours que j'ai entendu du Centre d'action laïque, on pouvait entendre, par exemple, qu'il s'oppose à toute forme de dogme.
Oui.
À partir du moment où on s'oppose à toute forme de dogme, c'est qu'on s'oppose à toute forme de religion, implicitement.
Non, parce qu'en fait, ça dépend quel est le sujet qui s'oppose à toute forme de dogme. C'est-à-dire que pour moi, s'opposer à toute forme de dogme,
c'est s'opposer à ce que l'État, par l'intermédiaire de ses lois, m'impose des dogmes auxquels je ne souscris pas.
C'est, si je prends l'exemple
du mariage homosexuel. Un État qui interdit au couple homosexuel de se marier, pour moi, c'est un État qui entérine un raisonnement très religieux, qui consiste à dire : le mariage
c'est une institution religieuse qui vient, comment dire, concrétiser, matérialiser l'union d'un homme et d'une femme, point.
Et l'État n'a pas à m'imposer ce dogme.
OK, donc c'est-
Après, libre à moi, si je veux, de dire : moi, je suis catholique et je trouve qu'un homme et une femme, c'est la seule façon possible de vivre une relation amoureuse.
Mais c'est moi, c'est pas l'État.
Donc on s'oppose à toute forme de dogme au niveau de l'État.
Oui, c'est ça.
Strictement.
Oui, oui.
Et pas de manière générale. D'accord, oui, effectivement, c'est une précision importante, pas toujours faite dans le discours du Centre d'action laïque.
Sur la même ligne de pensée, finalement, quand vous luttez activement contre la présence de cours de religion, d'importance de...
voilà, vous luttez activement contre le port de signes confessionnels, enfin, vous militez, disons, dans ce sens.
Finalement, en militant dans ce sens-là, est-ce que vous ne faites pas, à terme, le nid d'un futur athéisme ? Est-ce qu'en empêchant ces écoles d'être ouvertement religieuses, vous ne lui enlevez pas finalement son appareil reproducteur ?
Oh là ! J'aimerais bien, mais c'est pas si simple.
Analogie douteuse,
oui. Mais c'est finalement un petit peu comme ça que ça marche. La raison pour laquelle il y a eu donc au XIXe siècle,
des affrontements très importants entre Parti libéral et Parti catholique autour des écoles, c'était aussi dans un contexte électoral, parce que ces écoles-là étaient des usines à futurs...
ces écoles-là, qui étaient donc déjà à l'époque très majoritairement catholiques, étaient des usines à futurs électeurs du Parti catholique.
Mmm-hmm. Oui.
Dans la même logique, est-ce que
diminuer le plus possible l'importance du catholicisme, bon,
je parle du catholicisme parce que c'est l'élément le plus important, mais de toutes les religions possibles, dans nos écoles, est-ce que ça n'a pas finalement pour effet de créer de futurs agnostiques, de futurs athées ?
Ben je ne sais pas, en fait. Je suis pas du tout sûre que ça se fasse aussi facilement. En tout cas, moi, ce qui m'importe, c'est que la religion devienne davantage une affaire privée, en fait.
Ça m'intéresse pas tellement de convaincre qui que ce soit que Dieu n'existe pas. Enfin, c'est vraiment pas là-dedans que je-
Je n'étais pas en train de dire qu'on allait apprendre l'athéisme à l'école.
Non, non, je sais bien, je comprends bien, mais je veux dire que... enfin, j'avais envie de le préciser parce que tout à l'heure, on parlait de laïcité politique et de laïcité philosophique.
Et autant mon combat, c'est vraiment de faire en sorte que les règles religieuses ne s'imposent qu'aux seuls croyants, c'est-à-dire que jamais l'État ne m'impose une règle qui serait une règle religieuse.
Ça, c'est vraiment mon combat. Par contre, je n'ai absolument pas envie de faire en sorte que les gens modifient leurs croyances personnelles.
Je voudrais juste qu'ils se rendent compte que ce ne sont jamais que leurs croyances personnelles.
Vous n'êtes pas antithéiste.
Je suis... Voilà, je suis pas antireligieuse, je suis anticléricale, clairement, mais je suis pas du tout antireligieuse.
Vous pouvez peut-être définir un petit peu l'anticléricalisme par rapport à l'antithéisme ? Quelle est la différence ?
Oui, ben alors, l'anticléricalisme, c'est le refus d'accepter qu'une religion, quelle qu'elle soit, se mêle de politique, en fait.
Oui, donc c'est une approche laïque, en fait.
Ben oui.
Oui, c'est ça.
C'est pour ça que pour moi, la laïcité est de toute évidence anticléricale. C'est, 'fin, pour moi, c'est quasiment des synonymes, quoi. C'est lié.
Est-ce que vous estimez qu'on peut être... Est-ce que vous estimiez que le féminisme était presque synonyme avec la laïcité et que les deux travaillaient main dans la main ?
Ou non. Enfin, ce serait trop beau. Je pense que l'un a donné lieu à l'autre.
D'accord.
Mais il faut bien reconnaître en même temps que les premiers théoriciens de la laïcité n'étaient pas du tout des féministes, hein.
Je veux dire, 'fin, faut pas rêver non plus, quoi, hein.
Oui, historiquement, oui. Je veux plutôt parler d'aujourd'hui, oui.
Mais pour moi, philosophiquement, c'est lié. Je veux dire, à partir du moment où on reconnaît que l'État n'a pas à se mêler d'un certain nombre de choses, ou à prendre en compte un certain nombre de choses.
Donc si philosophiquement, c'est lié-
Mmm-hmm.
...est-ce qu'il est possible d'être féministe et catholique ?
Oui, à condition de s'autoriser quand même un fameux détachement par rapport aux dogmes catholiques.
Oui ? Est-ce qu'on peut être catholique en s'autorisant un détachement du dogme catholique ?
Ben oui, je pense qu'il y a des parcours individuels qui l'illustrent, même si c'est vrai que moi, ça me questionne toujours.
'Fin, je veux dire, bon, pour prendre un exemple, on sait à quel point le Vatican continue à dire que la contraception n'est pas une bonne chose selon lui.
Et en même temps, évidemment, la plupart des couples catholiques recourent à la contraception. Et donc, quelque part
il s'autorise à dire que le pape n'est pas infaillible, alors que c'est quand même un fameux dogme catholique, ça, l'infaillibilité papale.
Donc, je ne sais pas comment ils font avec leur conscience. Je ne sais pas comment ils se débrouillent pour tenir les deux, mais le fait est qu'ils y arrivent.
Donc moi, ça me paraît compliqué intellectuellement de dire : Tiens, c'est quand même curieux. Est-ce qu'ils ne sont pas devenus quelque part protestants en faisant ça ?
Mais manifestement, ils le font.
Puisqu'on parle du catholicisme, on observe depuis, alors je ne sais pas quelle est la temporalité exacte, mais on observe depuis quelques décennies un phénomène comme quoi les églises se vident petit à petit.
Je le vois très bien avec ma génération par rapport aux générations anciennes. Et à l'inverse, côté musulman, on voit peut-être un peu plus une réaffirmation, une réappropriation, un certain mouvement identitaire.
On va évoquer les deux, mais d'abord, dans un premier temps, les églises qui se vident, comment est-ce que vous expliquez ça, finalement ?
C'est arrivé par hasard ?
Non, je pense pas que ce soit un hasard. Pourquoi est-ce que les églises se vident ?
Vous donnez votre langue au chat.
Oui, j'avoue que ce n'est pas une question qui me...
C'est quand même intéressant.
Oui, oui.
Vous disiez évidemment que vous ne souhaitez pas activement convertir à l'athéisme, mais c'est quand même important de savoir si, à terme, dans quelques années, l'athéisme sera bien plus important qu'il ne l'est aujourd'hui.
Ça, je ne crois pas, en fait. Moi, je n'ai pas l'impression que l'athéisme progresse. J'ai l'impression que ce qui progresse, par contre, c'est un rapport de plus en plus personnel au religieux.
D'accord.
En tout cas-
On ne va pas à l'église, mais on reste-
Oui, oui.
Sous le...
Oui, c'est ça. On reste dans le giron, on reste des catholiques de tradition, de... Voilà, pour les grands événements, on continue à aller à l'église, mais en même temps, la religion n'est peut-être plus aussi présente dans le quotidien.
Ça, c'est ce qu'on appelle la sécularisation, en fait, un phénomène social qui définit le fait que les gens se réfèrent de moins en moins à la religion dans leurs faits et gestes de la vie quotidienne quoi.
Ils ne se demandent pas à tout bout de champ ce que Dieu veut quand il s'agit de se lever le matin, de savoir si on se brosse les dents, si on déjeune ou pas, etc.
Enfin, des trucs pareils.
Justement, quand moi, je me brosse les dents et que je réfléchis à cette question-là des églises qui se vident,
il m'apparaît que déjà en Belgique, vous allez me dire si vous pensez que je suis complètement dans le faux, mais il m'apparaît qu'en Belgique, on est relativement aisé par rapport au reste du monde.
On est, je crois, le deuxième ou troisième pays européen le plus riche, en moyenne, en général. Ça ne veut pas dire que tout le monde est riche, mais voilà, en général.
Et il y a des statistiques, des corrélations qui ont été faites pour montrer que plus un pays était pauvre, plus il était activement religieux, plus il allait à l'église.
Donc voilà, disons que la force motrice qui amène vers l'église, qui serait la pauvreté, est peut-être moins présente en Belgique qu'ailleurs.
Donc Marx serait raison quoi.
Et par ailleurs, Internet, l'information, les médias, le fait de ne pas avoir que l'église au milieu du village pour s'informer, de savoir quoi penser.
Voilà, ce sont des choses qui, alors je n'y connais rien, mais ce sont des choses qui m'apparaissent comme contribuant à un épanouissement, à une ouverture d'esprit vis-à-vis du dogme catholique traditionnel.
Oui, je pense qu'il y a une, ce qu'on peut appeler une crise de la religiosité ou en tout cas une individualisation du rapport au religieux.
Je pense aujourd'hui, en tout cas parmi les gens qui sont de traditions chrétiennes, ce à quoi on n'assiste pas dans l'islam, par contre.
Oui, justement.
Là, c'est plutôt l'inverse.
Comment est-ce que vous expliquez ce mouvement inverse qu'on voit, par exemple, dans les quartiers musulmans de Bruxelles, où il y a une réaffirmation de ces identités religieuses ?
Je crois qu'il y a déjà dans l'islam même un projet beaucoup plus rassembleur. Je dirais le message quand même de départ de l'islam, c'est de substituer à une société clanique l'égalité au sein de la Ummah, la communauté des croyants.
D'accord.
Il y a quand même un projet assez ambitieux et égalitaire qui consiste à dire, au fond, quelles que soient nos différences de statut social, etc., nous sommes tous frères et sœurs en islam, c'est ça qui compte.
Oui, les frontières, etc.
Voilà. Donc ça, c'est quand même très rassembleur. Je pense qu'on trouve moins ça dans le christianisme, de manière en tout cas moins affirmée.
C'est très rassembleur, mais il y a aussi les chiites, les sunnites, des mouvements qui ne veulent pas du tout se croiser.
C'est vrai, mais en même temps, le sunnisme est hyper majoritaire, donc finalement, les chiites sont assez anecdotiques.
Quand on parle d'islam en Belgique, on parle pour l'hyper majorité d'un islam sunnite. Et en plus de ça, évidemment, l'islam, en tout cas en Europe, est lié au phénomène migratoire.
Et donc, je crois qu'il fait office d'identité de substitution quoi, aussi.
Je crois que le fait de se tourner vers l'islam quand on a grandi en Belgique ou en France et de se tourner vers une pratique religieuse importante, c'est aussi une manière de chercher une identité
dans un contexte où c'est parfois compliqué de la trouver.
Bon, c'est une formule un peu bateau, mais bon, en même temps, tout le monde le sait. Je veux dire que les
jeunes d'origine turque ou marocaine de Belgique, ici, on continue à leur dire qu'ils sont turcs ou marocains et quand ils retournent ou quand ils vont en Turquie ou au Maroc, on les considère comme les Belges.
Donc nulle part, finalement, ils ne se sentent chez eux. Ils sont toujours considérés comme ceux qui viennent d'ailleurs quoi, où qu'ils soient.
Finalement, ceux qui se plaignent d'une forme de radicalisation, d'une forme de...
Réaffirmation, voilà, qu'on observe chez les musulmans ici en Belgique, sont peut-être aussi ceux qui sont un peu responsables puisque ce sont les mêmes personnes qui sont un peu xénophobes.
Je me méfie des discours trop victimaire parce que je pense qu'il faut quand même pas déconner. Enfin, je veux dire l'islam est malade et il est pas malade seulement en Occident.
Je veux dire, il est malade en Arabie Saoudite, il est malade en Iran, il est malade au Yémen et on y est pour rien.
Enfin, je veux dire, il faut pas voir non plus le grand Satan américain partout derrière tous les... Non, mais c'est vrai.
Je veux dire, il y a vraiment une maladie de l'islam aujourd'hui,
qui ne s'explique pas seulement par les phénomènes migratoires, par la difficulté, la quête identitaire de nos musulmans, entre guillemets, en Belgique ou ailleurs en Europe.
Mais je pense qu'on a malgré tout effectivement une part peut-être de responsabilité dans la mesure où,
comme je le dis souvent pour caricaturer un peu, quand on est enseignant et qu'on voit arriver un petit gamin à l'école le premier jour et qui s'appelle Mustapha,
on n'a rien de plus pressé que de lui demander d'où il vient et d'insister pour qu'il avoue
qu'il vient d'ailleurs, alors qu'en fait, lui, peut-être qu'il se sent tout à fait belge, né en Belgique et qu'il comprend même pas notre question.
Ce qui, pour le coup, n'est pas une approche très laïque.
Pas du tout. Et donc on est ravi quand enfin, il avoue qu'il vient du Maroc, même si en fait, il vient pas du tout du Maroc, hein, il est né ici et ses parents aussi.
Et par souci d'encenser la diversité, de montrer à quel point on est tolérant, etc. On va
tout au long de la scolarité de notre petit Mustapha mettre en évidence le fait qu'il a certainement un regard particulier à apporter parce qu'il vient d'ailleurs.
Donc on va valoriser ça chez lui. Et puis à un moment donné, on va lui dire : « Mais enfin, qu'est-ce qui se passe ? On a un problème avec l'immigration, l'intégration ne s'est pas faite.
Ces gens continuent à se dire marocains alors qu'en fait, ils sont belges. » Et je pense qu'effectivement, nous avons, oui, quand même une part de responsabilité par rapport à ça.
On peut pas dire à quelqu'un pendant quinze ans, vingt ans : « Oui OK, d'accord, t'es belge, ta carte d'identité est belge, mais dis-nous quand même d'où tu viens et d'où tes parents viennent et quelles sont tes racines, etc.
» Et donc le traiter tout le temps comme un étranger. Et puis après, s'étonner que lui-même finisse par se sentir étranger.
Bon, là, à un moment donné...
Ouais, non, voilà, c'est toute la parade des trucs. Le serpent qui se mord la queue.
Oui, oui, oui.
Justement, puisqu'on parle de l'islam, on parle de la laïcité, on parle des écoles, on va venir sur the elephant in the room. Ça va ?
Il y avait un éléphant dans la pièce ?
Le port du voile-
Oui
...dans les écoles, qui est un petit peu un sujet récurrent avec vous. Pour remettre un petit peu les choses en contexte, vous l'avez dit, je crois, 95 % des écoles interdisent dans leur règlement intérieur le port de signes religieux.
Ce qui, implicitement, voilà, c'est toujours... Ça n'est jamais dit explicitement que c'est le port du voile islamique qui est ciblé, mais implicitement, c'est généralement à ça qu'on pense.
Du point de vue du gouvernement, il y a une approche neutre, c'est-à-dire qu'on laisse l'établissement décider. On ne prend pas parti dans le cabinet de Marie-Martine Schyns.
Est-ce qu'il n'y a pas finalement, dans ces 95 % d'établissements, une certaine hypocrisie quand on chasse le port de signes religieux ostentatoires et qu'après ça, on donne cours de religion ?
Il n'y a pas une certaine contradiction ?
Oui et non. Contradiction, sûrement. Hypocrisie, non, mais je pense que c'est vraiment un exemple de ce que moi, j'appelle le bricolage à la belge quoi.
C'est-à-dire que plutôt que de prendre des mesures de principe, c'est pour ça que j'aime la France, moi, c'est parce que c'est un pays de principes quoi.
On énonce des principes. Alors après, on n'est pas toujours à la hauteur, mais au moins, on les a énoncés. En Belgique, on est plutôt des bricoleurs quoi.
Donc on règle les questions au coup par coup, au cas par cas. Et donc on se retrouve aujourd'hui effectivement avec des mesures qui sont complètement contradictoires.
C'est-à-dire que d'un côté, on va dans toutes les écoles de l'enseignement officiel organiser maintenant, c'est une heure de cours hebdomadaire de religion au choix des élèves en fonction de leurs convictions.
Et dans le même temps, on leur dit : « Bah écoutez, quand vous rentrez à l'école, s'il vous plaît, débarrassez-vous de vos signes religieux parce que vous n'êtes pas là en tant que croyant, vous êtes là en tant qu'élève quoi.
» Donc c'est... Enfin, il perd son latin quoi. Enfin, c'est très contradictoire.
Je veux dire, est-ce que la religion est dans l'école ? Est-ce qu'elle est en dehors ? Est-ce qu'on est censé la laisser à l'extérieur ou est-ce qu'on est censé la faire rentrer dans l'école ?
Et on dit les deux à la fois. À la fois, on organise l'instruction religieuse des élèves et en même temps, on leur dit : « S'il vous plaît, pas de signes religieux. » Enfin.
Il me semble que la question n'a jamais tout à fait été résolue et que même, ne soit pas pressé de se pencher sur le dossier qui est assez touchy.
Assez touchy, c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire. Oui. Oui, parce qu'évidemment, la question sous-jacente, c'est la question de la liberté religieuse.
C'est toujours ça, hein. Je veux dire, c'est pour ça, je pense que les différents ministres dits compétents ont toujours soigneusement évité de se poser la que-- enfin, de trancher cette question-là.
C'est parce qu'ils savent très bien que c'est un sujet à haut risque. Et donc, ils préfèrent un peu lâchement dire aux écoles : « Bah débrouillez-vous en fonction de vos réalités de terrain.
» Alors qu'en fait, les réalités de terrain, c'est souvent pour certaines écoles, ben,
soit dans certains cas, la nécessité d'interdire parce que c'est tout simplement plus gérable d'autoriser, soit l'impossibilité d'interdire, parce que si on interdit, on n'a plus d'élèves.
Donc on est très loin des principes. Là, on est dans des trucs à la limite très sordides quoi. Enfin, je veux dire, est-ce qu'on peut se permettre de perdre X élèves si on interdit demain ?
Vous pensez que dans les 5 % qui n'interdisent pas le port du voile, il y a ces logiques...
Mais oui, évidemment, parce que,
parce que ces écoles sont devenues de gré ou de force les écoles refuges, pour les parents qui souhaitent à toute force que leurs filles continuent à porter le voile ou pour les filles qui elles-mêmes continuent à,
à vouloir à toute force le porter.
Donc aujourd'hui, il y a des écoles dans lesquelles on ne va plus parce que c'est une école qui a un chouette projet, parce qu'elle est pas trop loin de la maison, parce qu'on y offre des formations de qualité, etc.
Mais on y va uniquement parce que là, on pourra porter le voile.
C'est ça.
Je sais pas si-
Donc y a-
Ça ne va pas.
Y a, oui, 'fin, alors, je ne connais pas la situation des écoles en question, mais sur le papier, là, j'ai l'impression qu'on est dans une situation un petit peu de ghetto.
Ah mais tout à fait. Oui, oui. Non, mais l'enseignement, en tout cas l'enseignement bruxellois est terriblement ghettoïsé.
Et moi, c'est quelque chose qui m'inquiète et qui me rend furieuse, aussi par le côté hypocrite, je veux dire, parce qu'il y a quand même peu de gens qui osent le dire.
Je veux dire, souvent, on parle-
Beaucoup de gens qui veulent bien le dire, mais qui en sont très satisfaits, au fond.
Ça aussi. Alors évidemment-
Que mon fils aille à l'école catholique-
Bien sûr
...Saint-Michel, plus-- où il n'y aura pas trop de musulmans, etc.
Évidemment. Oui, oui, y a ça. Et puis il y a le fait qu'on continue à parler d'écoles multiculturelles pour des écoles qui sont en fait monoculturelles.
C'est ça.
Je veux dire, mais on dit multiculturelle parce qu'y a pas de Belges de souche. C'est pour dire ça, pour le dire vite.
Mais en fait, ce sont des écoles monoculturelles et c'est un scandale, en fait. Je veux dire, 'fin, je pense que c'est vraiment pour moi, c'est la priorité, c'est l'urgence en matière d'instruction,
c'est de faire en sorte de revenir ou d'en venir enfin à des écoles qui soient vraiment des lieux de mixité socioculturelle, donc des lieux de brassage.
Parce que je pense que c'est une des missions fondamentales de l'école pour moi, c'est de sortir l'enfant de ses évidences, en fait, c'est de lui faire découvrir le monde.
Et le monde, c'est pas la famille, c'est pas le microcosme familial. C'est plein de manières de penser différentes, de voir les choses différentes, de vivre différentes.
Et si l'école devient une espèce de prolongement naturel de la famille où on retrouve exactement le même type de personnes qui pensent de la même façon, y a quelque chose qui-
Mmm-hmm. Echo chamber.
Voilà. Oui, tout à fait. Oui, oui.
Y a, oui, l'école a, comme vous le disiez, donc une certaine mission émancipatrice-
Oui, tout à fait
...de se, d'échapper à ses racines, qui n'y arrive pas vraiment-
Oui
...à partir du moment où on est dans cette situation-là.
Pour revenir au port du voile, plus précisément,
l'approche qui est la vôtre, qui est de dire que finalement, voilà, tous les élèves doivent venir avec une certaine ouverture d'esprit, en se, ben justement, en quittant leurs racines,
qu'elles soient religieuses ou autres, mais donc par exemple, dans le cas de la religion, en abandonnant le port de signes religieux.
C'est une approche donc laïque. Donc, comme on le disait, on ferme les yeux, on ne tient pas compte de tous ces facteurs et on demande une égalité en termes d'ouverture d'esprit à tous les élèves.
L'approche laïque, voilà, au sens dur. Quand on ferme les yeux sur ces facteurs-là, est-ce qu'on ne devient pas alors aveugle sur d'autres questions ?
Il est par exemple pas rare d'entendre les histoires de jeunes filles qui allaient dans une haute école à Uccle et que cette haute école
adapte son règlement et tout d'un coup, ah, le port de signes religieux n'est plus autorisé
et que donc, bien, cette femme adulte ne peut plus venir dans sa haute école avec son voile.
D'une personne qui donc considère son voile comme faisant partie de son identité, de sa culture et ne souhaite pas l'abandonner.
Voilà. Là, il y a une opposition avec la position laïque que vous défendez, comme quoi il faut une certaine ouverture d'esprit, il faut accepter de délaisser ses racines, entre guillemets, à la maison.
Mais concrètement, si on regarde juste le résultat de ça, ben on va voir finalement des jeunes musulmanes qui abandonnent leur éducation, qui quittent la haute école et qui vont se trouver une autre solution.
Donc, est-ce que finalement, en fermant les yeux sur ces facteurs-là, on ne devient pas aveugle à des conséquences socioéconomiques qui sont vécues par une communauté en particulier ?
Alors, je comprends votre question. Je suis évidemment pas tout à fait d'accord, au sens où je pense qu'il y a une erreur fondamentale
qui consiste, pas de votre part, mais de la part de ces jeunes filles musulmanes, qui consiste à rendre l'institution scolaire responsable, alors qu'en fait, le véritable responsable, c'est la religion.
En fait, c'est la religion qui met des freins, 'fin, la religion, c'est l'interprétation qu'elles font de leur religion ou l'interprétation qu'on leur a,
imposé de leur religion, qui en fait met des freins à leur émancipation.
Moi, je ne suis pas prête à renoncer à des principes qui me semblent tout à fait fondés et légitimes sous prétexte qu'il faut contribuer à développer l'accès à l'emploi pour tous.
Toute profession a ses règles et si on n'est pas prêt à s'y soumettre, ben il faut penser à changer de métier. 'Fin, je veux dire, je le dis platement, mais c'est quand même comme ça.
Je veux dire, bon, à mon époque, il y avait des punks. Ben si vous vouliez être punk et travailler dans une banque, ça n'allait pas le faire.
C'est pas possible. Et ça n'a pas de sens de dire : moi, je suis punk et je veux pouvoir aller avec mes épingles à nourrice enfoncées un peu partout, travailler derrière le guichet d'une banque au nom de la tolérance et du respect.
Ben non, y a un truc qui ne va pas.
Donc neutralité d'apparence. Pas seulement pour la religion, mais de manière générale, on peut pas être gothique, punk.
Oui, 'fin, alors, on peut être gothique et punk, mais on doit savoir qu'en faisant ce choix-là, on va se fermer certaines portes d'entrée et que c'est normal. Je veux dire, 'fin,
quand on est dans des professions où on est en contact avec le client, ben nécessairement, il faut respecter certaines règles qui peuvent passer pour des règles extrêmement conformistes, tout ce qu'on veut, et je,
et on peut discuter de ça, et les codes changent.
Et ce qui était inenvisageable il y a vingt ans est devenu tout à fait acceptable aujourd'hui. Je pense par exemple aux tatouages ou aux piercings, qui sont beaucoup plus acceptés aujourd'hui socialement qu'ils ne l'étaient,
quand moi, j'étais adolescente.
Mais pour ce qui concerne la neutralité de la fonction publique, ben moi, j'y suis attachée. Je trouve que c'est un principe fondamental d'égalité des citoyens devant la loi.
Je veux dire, 'fin, quand, je sais pas, si je comparais au tribunal, par exemple, je trouve que c'est extrêmement important que le juge soit dépourvu de tout signe convictionnel, parce que sinon,
je pourrais légitimement avoir l'impression que son jugement est biaisé par ses convictions qu'il affiche.
Mais finalement, vous n'auriez— si son apparence est complètement neutre, vous n'aurez pas cette impression, mais peut-être qu'il a des convictions qu'il n'affiche pas—
Alors ça, c'est—
Et qu'il est biaisé.
Oui, alors ça, c'est le sempiternel faux débat—
Excusez-moi—
Non, non, mais c'est pas grave, c'est pas à vous que j'en veux, mais c'est vrai que c'est une question qui m'a souvent été posée.
Parce qu'on oppose souvent la neutralité d'apparence à la neutralité de service. Et pour moi, évidemment, les deux vont de pair.
Il ne s'agit pas de dire : il faut être neutre d'apparence, mais du coup, on peut faire ce qu'on veut.
Je veux simplement dire qu'avant même de commencer à interagir avec une personne, l'apparence qu'on a a une influence sur le sentiment qu'elle va avoir de pouvoir être accueillie—
Ouais.
De manière neutre. On parlait tout à l'heure des hôpitaux.
Oui.
Si vous êtes une jeune femme, 'fin, ou une jeune fille de quinze ans enceinte et que vous entrez dans un hôpital pour demander un avortement et que la personne sur qui vous tombez porte un grand crucifix en bois,
il est tout à fait envisageable que vous ne vous sentiez pas parfaitement à l'aise pour formuler votre demande.
C'est curieux parce que vous prenez l'approche de se sentir plutôt que d'être traité de manière neutre.
Ben parce qu'avant même d'avoir parlé, c'est celle-là, c'est là que je veux en venir. Ma jeune fille enceinte, elle va d'abord voir, elle va entrer en contact visuel avec quelqu'un.
Et à partir du moment où on est dans un service au public, à la population, je trouve que c'est de la part de,
du fonctionnaire ou du travailleur qui accueille la jeune fille, il doit tout mettre en œuvre pour qu'elle ose formuler sa demande.
Mh.
C'est sa responsabilité à lui. Il est à son service à elle, c'est pas l'inverse. C'est une étape symbolique aussi, je pense.
Le fait de— pour revenir à l'école, par exemple, moi, je crois quand même fort à des actes symboliques qui ont un sens.
Je veux dire, enlever quelque chose de religieux quand on rentre dans une classe,
pour moi, ça marque le fait qu'on est conscient du fait qu'on franchit une frontière et qu'on change de monde, on change de sphère, on est passé de quelque chose vers autre chose.
Et ça se marque symboliquement par le fait qu'on enlève quelque chose. Moi, 'fin, je pense que c'est pas juste comme ça, juste pour faire joli, juste pour, 'fin—
Mais donc vous faites finalement fi,
si vous voyez un graphique qui montre que, voilà, davantage de filles musulmanes ont arrêté leurs études supérieures le jour où leur établissement scolaire a interdit le port des signes religieux,
vous feriez fi alors de ce graphique-là en disant : « Ben le réel responsable, c'est leur foi, c'est leur religion, c'est leur,
voilà, leur interprétation du Coran. »
Ben oui, c'est-à-dire que pour moi, c'est à un moment donné, 'fin, c'est dommage pour elles, c'est vraiment très triste pour elles, mais je ne me sens pas responsable de ça.
Je pense que le véritable combat qu'elles doivent mener, c'est contre ceux qui continuent à véhiculer aujourd'hui une,
une conception de la religion islamique qui est terriblement enfermante pour les femmes et qui les met dans des situations de ce genre-là.
Mh.
'Fin, ce qui est quand même d'autant plus surréaliste que je rappelle quand même que dans le Coran, y a rien qui dit clairement qu'il faut se couvrir la chevelure.
Je veux dire, donc, on est vraiment là, pour moi, dans un exemple tout à fait emblématique de prise de pouvoir des hommes sur les femmes par le biais d'un truc soi-disant religieux, mais qui n'a rien de religieux.
Il y a aussi peut-être un petit peu une certaine dérive identitaire dans ce— au final, de se dire, qui s— ben oui, c'est ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure sur qui suis-je réellement ?
Ne suis-je pas marocaine ? Je ne me sens pas tout à fait belge et trouver une identité grâce à la religion. Donc on suit la religion plus que—
Oui.
Dans un autre contexte et donc on porte un voile.
Oui, sauf que justement, 'fin, moi, c'est ça qui m'agace prodigieusement dans cette histoire de voile, c'est que, je veux dire, quand on voit les jeunes musulmans aujourd'hui à Bruxelles,
les hommes n'ont pas l'air particulièrement tiraillés par le besoin d'affirmer extérieurement leur appartenance religieuse.
Je veux dire, les mecs, ils se baladent en casquette et en basket, et en jeans—
Mais là—
'Fin—
Oui, mais là, vous vous heurtez au mur où on va simplement vous répondre que les deux sexes sont différents et qu'ils sont égaux en termes d'opportunités, mais pas tout à fait vraiment.
Oui, mais c'est là que moi, je vois justement dans le voile. Pour moi, c'est clairement un outil de contrôle sur le corps des femmes quoi.
C'est une façon pour les hommes, parce que je pense que les religions monothéistes sont quand même des créations humaines et masculines.
'Fin, c'est quand même toujours une manière de dire aux femmes : « Voilà, attention, tu as une liberté, mais une liberté conditionnelle. »
C'est ça.
Tu peux pas faire ce que tu veux de toi. 'Fin... Et donc, à certains moments, ben oui, tu vas devoir choisir, du coup, entre être une bonne musulmane et une femme émancipée, heureuse, accomplie.
Et c'est ça qui est révoltant pour moi. Et c'est contre ça que je pense que les femmes musulmanes aujourd'hui devraient plus massivement se lever.
'Fin, je veux dire, elles le font en Iran, et c'est tant mieux, mais elles le font peut-être pas encore tout à fait assez dans nos pays occidentaux où elles considèrent leur religion comme—
'fin, sans avoir toujours le recul nécessaire, c'est-à-dire qu'elles y voient uniquement un facteur d'émancipation, de liberté, d'accomplissement, d'identité, etc.
Et n'ont pas toujours cette démarche de questionnement sur ce qui peut être dans leur religion, les emprisonne et les empêche d'être libres.
On évoquait il y a un instant les changements que vous souhaiteriez voir apparaître au sein de l'enseignement obligatoire du côté francophone, du côté belge francophone, puisque c'est de ça qu'on parle.
Vient alors la question du politique, paysage politique belge, la question électorale, très importante quand on évoque ces sujets-là.
J'ai l'impression que finalement, aucun parti ne souhaite vraiment se pencher sur les questions de laïcité affirmée,
de l'enseignement catholique, du financement des cultes, principalement pour des raisons électorales et que c'est vraiment un terrain dangereux pour eux.
Oui, alors, je vais nuancer un peu, même si je suis d'accord pour l'essentiel. On a quand même deux grands partis qui, à l'origine, sont des partis laïcs et anticléricaux, qui sont le PS et les libéraux.
Le Mouvement réformateur.
Oui, aujourd'hui devenu le Mouvement réformateur. Alors, je pense que le MR est, pour des raisons évidentes, plus courageux sur les questions de laïcité que le PS.
On peut préciser ? Raisons évidentes ?
Je pense que son élec— Il va moins chercher son électorat dans la population musulmane, tout simplement.
D'accord, ouais.
Et que donc, il risque moins en termes de perte de voix, tout simplement.
Donc, vous mettez en opposition la question de laïcité avec la population musulmane, mais pas catholique ? Enfin, c'est finalement une partie importante de la population aussi.
Oui, c'est vrai. C'est parce qu'on a parlé de plusieurs choses très différentes. En fait, on a parlé de la fin du financement de l'enseignement confessionnel.
Le Mouvement réformateur a aussi un électorat, une partie de l'électorat—
Oui, une branche plus—
Catholique.
...chrétienne conservatrice.
Ouais.
Oui, oui, clairement. Oui, oui.
Donc voilà, je suppose que ça entraîne certaines—
Ça dépend des mesures. Si vous parlez de mettre fin au financement de l'enseignement confessionnel, là, je crois que personne n'a envie de lever ce lièvre-là.
Hum. Pour des raisons financières aussi ?
Oui, et parce— oui, pour des raisons financières, mais aussi pour des raisons, je pense, d'opportunités politiques.
Je veux dire, bon, à partir du moment où l'enseignement confessionnel draine quand même une majorité d'enfants, ben forcément, on peut supposer que parmi ces enfants, il y a beaucoup de parents d'électeurs, 'fin, qui traversent tous les partis.
Mais je veux dire, 'fin, si on décide que l'enseignement confessionnel demain ne sera plus financé par l'État, ben, on va faire plein de parents mécontents qui sont des parents qui votent pour le MR ou pour le PS ou pour Ecolo.
C'est vraiment une logique électorale de dire—
Oui, oui. Oui, oui.
On ne veut pas heurter les sensibilités.
Donc, par contre, quand je parlais d'un courage plus grand, 'fin, ou en tout cas d'un positionnement peut-être plus courageux du MR, je parlais plutôt des signes religieux.
Parce que là, je pense qu'effectivement—
Oui, puisque là, on ne se heurte pas aux sensibilités catholiques, mais plutôt aux sensibilités musulmanes.
Exactement, oui. Donc, le PS, par rapport à ça, dans mon analyse, est un parti qui est assez mou, voire même parfois complaisant sur la question.
On se rappelle du bourgmestre Philippe Moureaux à Molenbeek, il y a une dizaine d'années, qui, oui, était effectivement dans une certaine complaisance.
Voilà, mais à côté de ça, il laisse exister des francs-tireurs qui, à titre personnel, défendent la laïcité, qui sont un peu minorisés au sein de leur parti.
Mais enfin, bon, voilà, c'est un peu folklorique qu'ils existent, c'est sympa. Et ces gens-là drainent un électorat aussi, donc c'est pas plus mal.
Alors, à côté de ça, il y a Ecolo. Et pour moi, Ecolo, il est complètement, je dirais, à la masse par rapport à tout ça.
D'accord.
C'est-à-dire que pour moi, c'est un parti qui n'a jamais bien compris ces enjeux-là, qui est arrivé probablement après.
Il n'a pas cette histoire-là. Je veux dire, la tradition socialiste et la tradition libérale sont des traditions d'opposition aux partis catholiques.
Donc, il y a quand même cette mémoire qui subsiste dans les partis.
Oui, et puis le, Jean-Michel Javaux était ouvertement catholique, etc.
Aussi, oui, oui, ça n'aide pas. Oui, oui. Donc, malheureusement, Ecolo, malgré toute la sympathie que je peux avoir pour certains autres aspects de leur programme, sur ce plan-là, je crois qu'ils sont,
ils ne prennent pas la mesure des enjeux, je pense.
Et alors, bon, il y a quand même Défi, qui est quand même un parti qui s'affiche clairement laïque.
D'accord.
Je trouve que ça vaut quand même la peine d'être précisé.
Oui, OK.
Et puis évidemment, à l'autre bout, il y a le CDH qui...
CDH, on précise, ancien... C'était quoi ? C'est le—
Le Centre démocrate humaniste, qui était avant le PSC, quoi, le Parti social chrétien. Oui, oui.
Oui, oui. Donc là, forcément, oui. Qui, voilà, qui est donc ce parti qui est aux commandes du ministère de l'Éducation depuis maintenant dix ans, je crois.
Tout à fait, oui, oui.
Oui. Et qui donc prône une certaine neutralité, ne veut pas trop toucher à ces dossiers.
Oui, oui, clairement.
C'est assez clair. Mais au fond, pourquoi ? Parce que c'est des catholiques, donc ils n'ont pas peur de se heurter à leur électorat catholique s'ils interdisent explicitement le port du voile.
Non, mais c'est— alors, on revient à ce que je dis tout à l'heure sur la mentalité—
Oui, ne pas blesser.
Ne pas blesser, ne pas choquer, tenir compte des sensibilités religieuses des uns et des autres, etc. Enfin...
Oui, c'est— on se rappelle de Joëlle Milquet face à vous dans un débat. Surtout, il ne voulait pas s'énerver surtout. Il voulait qu'on évoque calmement les questions de la laïcité et de l'enseignement confessionnel.
Oui, tout à fait. Oui, oui.
Ouais. Maintenant, finalement, vous avez fait un petit peu le tour du paysage politique belge francophone. Et donc finalement, l'aspect républicain, l'aspect laïque, il faut le chercher.
Ce n'est pas le fer de lance d'un parti en particulier.
Ah non, non, non, non, non. Mais ça, je pense que c'est, que ce soit pour la République, pour la laïcité, moi, je pense que le point commun, c'est qu'il faudra que les choses viennent de la base, quoi.
D'en bas.
Oui.
Une révolte du peuple.
Ah oui. Par exemple, n'exagérons pas, mais je pense qu'il faut qu'à un moment donné, le politique sente qu'il y a une demande dans la population.
Je crois que ce n'est pas le genre de dossier dont il s'empare de gaieté de cœur en se disant : « Allons-y, la fleur au fusil et voilà, et c'est important et on y croit », etc.
Je pense que non. Il faut qu'il y ait des signaux clairs qui émanent de la population qui dit : « Il y a un problème, il faut gérer telle ou telle chose, il faut cesser avec le deux poids, deux mesures ou les attitudes peu claires, etc. » quoi.
Et ce désir de la population, aujourd'hui, on en est où ? C'est— est-ce que c'est une très faible minorité ou est-ce qu'on se rapproche d'une majorité ? Parce que...
Par rapport à la laïcité, plus précisément ?
Disons les deux, disons à la fois la laïcité et la République.
La République, je pense que ce n'est pas pour demain.
Je pense que l'immense majorité des gens
sont d'accord avec moi sur le principe,
sur le fait qu'effectivement, il y a quelque chose d'anachronique et d'antidémocratique dans la monarchie et qu'en même temps, il y a des problèmes tellement plus importants qu'on ne va pas risquer une révolution ou la fin de la Belgique.
Il faudrait un méga scandale au niveau de la monarchie.
Oui, voilà. Oui, je pense que vraiment, si on avait aujourd'hui un deuxième Baudouin qui refusait de signer une loi éthique importante.
Là, je crois que franchement, la monarchie pourrait trembler sur ses bases. Mais on a, je crois, des rois bien conseillés.
Mmh.
Et donc ils évitent soigneusement ce genre de boulettes parce que je pense que ça passerait plus. Je pense que c'est passé une fois, mais ça passerait plus, je crois.
Mais on parlait du paysage politique belge francophone.
Mmh.
Du côté néerlandophone, on sait que le projet républicain est au cœur du projet de la N-VA, par exemple.
Ben oui, mais alors du côté néerlandophone, c'est tout à fait différent parce qu'il y a évidemment des Flamands qui sont simplement républicains,
mais il y a aussi beaucoup de Flamands pour qui la République n'est jamais qu'une manière d'obtenir une République indépendante flamande.
Mmh.
Et donc ce sont deux questions différentes, je veux dire.
Le Palais royal est finalement un obstacle.
Oui, voilà, c'est ça. Exactement.
Oui.
Oui. Et donc évidemment que si on imagine constituer demain un nouveau pays, je crois que plus personne ne dirait : « Tiens, on va créer une monarchie », quoi.
Oui, c'est sûr.
C'est évident.
Du coup, la question qui s'impose, c'est que finalement, ben la N-VA est au pouvoir actuellement et pourtant le dossier n'est pas du tout mis sur la table. Ils ont...
Parce que je pense qu'ils ont d'autres priorités à l'agenda quoi, tout simplement.
Oui, c'est ça.
Tout simplement. Et alors pour ce qui est de la laïcité, moi, je suis plus inquiète par rapport à ça parce que j'ai l'impression que le
fait qu'il y a aujourd'hui des difficultés et, bon, je pense que sans mauvais jeu de mots, il faut pas se voiler la face quoi.
Je pense que la plupart des questions qui se posent aujourd'hui en termes de présence du religieux sont des questions liées à l'islam.
Par rapport à ça, je crois que le fait qu'il y ait pas de réponse claire, structurelle et principielle venant de l'État nourrit un discours qui est un discours en fait de rejet de l'islam en tant que tel.
Éventuellement même en lui opposant une réaffirmation des valeurs chrétiennes et de la tradition chrétienne en Belgique.
Donc tout sauf un discours laïque. Moi, c'est ça qui m'inquiète en fait, c'est que mon propos, ça n'est absolument pas de mener, de monter une communauté religieuse contre une autre.
C'est de dire : voilà, il faudrait qu'on mette les choses à plat et qu'une fois pour toutes, on affirme que la religion n'a rien à faire dans la sphère du politique.
Nadia Geerts, nous arrivons malheureusement au bout de Septante Minutes. Ce fut un plaisir de vous accueillir aujourd'hui dans ce podcast.
Encore merci d'être venue.
Avec plaisir.
Au revoir.
Et voilà, c'est déjà tout pour ce huitième épisode. Comme souvent, quand on parle de Belgique, c'est difficile de ne pas évoquer la question du communautarisme comme on l'a fait rapidement quand on a évoqué les plans républicains à la N-VA.
Ce sera le sujet du prochain épisode où mon invité, qui est professeur à Harvard, à Oxford et à l'Université catholique de Louvain, nous parlera de l'avenir de la Belgique en tant que nation.
À part ça, n'oubliez pas de nous suivre sur Facebook, Twitter et de laisser cinq étoiles sur iTunes. À dans deux semaines. Bye bye.